wir müssen doch mal gerade überlegen wir
hatten ja heute die regierung für die
überraschungsmenü was bei den gästen
machen
lukas was hast du davor schleife mit
vorspeise ich prüfe und zucchini so
etwas machen wir das was machst du fünf
leicht ich habe mein fähnchen brust
kartoffel strudel und danach haben wir
das mal überlegen
ich hab ihr präparat das mit dem
schmecken ich hoffe die hatten
sonderwünsche waren da nicht bisher
nicht aber wenn noch irgendwas kommt
fragt ja nochmal gar nicht bescheiden
wir heute mit den zehner tisch dann
haben wir das überraschungsmenü dann
haben wir glaube ich ein geburtstag für
viele nun und die bestände bei aller
karten dann machen wir
glosse da war taktisch 8 kann mich
einmal alle gegen sarah ob da alles im
menü und wenn der sonstige sonderwünsche
kommen jetzt sind wir dann noch eine
chance
[Musik]